angesichts der neuen pläne dürfte sich
die stimmung her weiter verschärfen auch
gestern wieder corona demonstrationen in
deutschland und wieder kam es zu
ausschreitungen
hier sehen wir bilder aus mannheim
demonstranten die auf polizisten
einprügeln gewaltsam gegen die maßnahme
der beamten vorgehen 13 polizisten
wurden verletzt ein beamter wurde ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert
rund 800 menschen zeigten bei der
verbotenen demonstration in der baden
württembergischen stadt ihren unmut
gegen die korona maßnahmen 13
demonstranten wurden festgenommen
und auch in anderen deutschen städten
wie rostock schwerin oder magdeburg in
zahlreiche menschen zum demonstrieren
auf die straße die impfpflicht das ist
das thema das sind ganz deutschland die
gemüter erhitzt in der ganzen republik
sind in den letzten wochen menschen auf
die straßen gegangen unsere reporter
klarer becker und til biermann haben
sich diese demonstration mal ganz genau
angesehen sie waren in sechs tagen auf 8
demos in sieben verschiedenen städten im
land um herauszufinden wer geht da
wirklich auf die straße impfmuffel im
skeptiker impfgegner querdenker
verschwörungstheoretiker reichs bürger
rechtsextreme kann man wirklich alle
über einen kamm scheren
ein samstag in stuttgart auf dem
karlsplatz treffen sich rund 200
teilnehmer demonstriert wird gegen die
korona maßnahmen vor allem aber gegen
die kommende impfpflicht was wir hier
als argumente hören zum teil schlicht
absurd wie viele nebenwirkungen sind
wird nicht kommuniziert nur in medien
die man nicht schauen darf und sich
einfach in unmöglich zu sagen
krimineller zustand und fragen sind sie
selbst geimpft heinz schleicher dich
dabei never ever nur unter zwang würde
es nicht geben ich würde mich nie im
finanz- und wie ich gehört dort gibt es
schon gefängnissen dann gehe ich mit
gefängnis und lieber lasse ich nicht
erschießen das könnte ich machen könnte
machen wie im dritten reich es sind
diese aussagen der sogenannten
querdenker die uns erschaudern lassen so
oder so ähnlich sehen es hier viele
protestler im ländle was sie eint ist
die gut auf den staat die medien
misstrauen gegen die korona maßnahmen
und viel platz nach rechts außen um
zwang und protest geht es auch in
hamburg nur wenige tage später
11.500 menschen ziehen mit plakaten
gegen die impfpflicht um die alster wer
in diesen zeiten freund und wer feind
ist wird schnell klar
den ich mir das überlegen
wir tun uns zur not nach russland
russland ausgerechnet russland der ort
kein zufall denn putin wird hier von
vielen als held verehrt angela merkel
und bill gates dagegen sind teil einer
internationalen verschwörung
auch in bernau bei berlin sprechenden
mitmenschen dieser skeptiker sieht in
der pandemie einen großen masterplan
durchziehen man will eine völlige
gesellschaftsveränderung
[Musik]
großer reset man sucht ein anlass gründe
gegen eine impfpflicht gäbe es
vielleicht einige gehört haben wir sie
nicht
wir haben ein absurdes sammelsurium an
menschen getroffen und gesprochen die
denken die wahrheit erkannt zu haben
hier verbreiten sich die verschwörungs
mythen ähnlich schnell wie das virus
dazu spricht ist unsere gesellschaft ist
nicht gespart
demo reise durch corona deutschland
klara marie becker und til biermann sind
jetzt bei uns im studio und berichten
uns von dieser reise schönen guten tag
euch beiden klar mit welchen
erkenntnissen kommt er von dieser reise
lief quer durch deutschland geführt habe
zurück wir haben auf jeden fall gemerkt
dass für menschen die auf die straße
gehen möchten um gegen die maßnahmen zu
demonstrieren die aktuell hier in
deutschland gelten aufgrund der korona
pandemie gibt es eigentlich was keine
demos mehr auf die sie einfach gehen
können um ihren unmut kund zu tun also
wir haben erlebt dass die menschen die
dort hingehen eben genau aus diesen
gründen immer wieder gesagt haben wir
werden in einer ecke geschoben und wir
möchten eigentlich auf die straße gehen
weil wir eben nicht zufrieden mit der
situation und wir haben natürlich auch
jetzt gerade gesehen es gibt eben auch
immer wieder viele auf diesen demos die
in eine bestimmte ecke rutschen in eine
in verschwörungstheorien abdriften und
dementsprechend ist es schwierig für
leute die einfach unmut haben auf diese
demos zu gehen habt ihr solche menschen
denn auch getroffen wir haben jetzt die
extrembeispiele gesehen sind denn
innerhalb dieser demonstrationsgruppen
auch die sagen wir normalen impfung
skeptisch
beispielsweise die einfach sagen ich
fühle mich nicht wohl bei der sache ja
allerdings war es wirklich schwierig
also ich hab auf 4 demos war ich und da
habe ich eine person getroffen das war
eine krankenschwester die sagte einfach
sehr einfach eine unglaubliche angst vor
diesen impfstoff sie sagte sie nehme
auch das virus ernst sie trägt auch
maske sie sieht ja auch im krankenhaus
dass menschen am virus sterben und
trotzdem hat sie einfach eine
unglaubliche angst vor diesen impfstoff
allerdings was sagt sie wenn sie die
anderen menschen dort in dieser gruppe
auch sieht mit denen sie vielleicht sich
nicht in einen topf schmeißen lassen
will na da sie so eine angst vor diesem
impfstoff hat versteht sie die auch
irgendwo und das heißt er vermischt sich
dann das vermischt sich ein bisschen und
das was mir halt auf wie manchmal sagen
die leute erstmal etwas was ich jetzt so
nachvollziehen kann sagen einfach ich
habe angst davor ich möchte noch warten
das muss man ja auch ernst nehmen finde
ich allerdings nach zwei drei fragen
sind sie dann sehr schnell die
allermeisten wirklich da das hinter
dieser ganze sache nicht stecke dass die
politiker sich irren oder so sondern
dass es eine große verschwörung ist dass
die global ist dass die rothschilds
dahinter stecken und das fällt auf es
einer wie so eine pandemie des wahns
weil die stecken sich quasi auch
untereinander an die erzählen sich das
dann sagt er eine zweite guck mal hier
bei telegramm und manche also ich jetzt
klarer wahrscheinlich auch nicht wie er
will wir sehen das denken wir glauben
das nicht aber bei manchen bleibt das
irgendwie hängen oder ist das auch
schwer wieder raus raus zu kriegen
telegramm hast du angesprochen klar die
hier organisieren sich diese menschen
viele demos die dann so weit gehen wenn
ja auch verboten wie läuft die
organisation untereinander ab ist es in
irgendeiner form überhaupt eine homogene
gruppe die das zusammentrifft
die leute organisieren sich vor allem
auf telegrammen also wir sind auch einer
gruppe beigetreten die eigentlich nichts
anderes macht als jeden tag neue termine
für demos dort zu veröffentlichen da
klingt das handy eigentlich auch
bestimmt 60 mal am tag also es wenn
wirklich jeden tag neue demo termine
rein gepostet es sind auch ja inzwischen
mehrere dutzende wenn nicht sogar
hunderte in ganz deutschland das sind
eben montagsspaziergänge also die leute
treffen sich haben keine angemeldete
demo die sie durchführen sondern treffen
sich zum spazieren gehen alle zusammen
das sind aber auch wirklich angemeldete
demo es teilweise und das wird
eigentlich größtenteils über telegramm
auch organisiert wir haben aber auch
schnell gemerkt es gibt auch viele demos
die in diesen gruppen gar nicht
auftauchen also die anscheinend auch
noch privater vielleicht über
irgendwelche privaten chats organisiert
werden wo wir jetzt gar keinen zugang zu
hatten viele gibt es irgendeine message
die wenn man jetzt abstrahiert von den
menschen die an verschwörungstheorien
glauben die wirres zeug glauben gibt es
eine these die duh ausstatten konntest
von menschen aus der eine
rationale unzufriedenheit spricht gab
kann also weiß erfassen was man was
wirklich einige geärgert hat war zum
beispiel
die fdp dass die gesagt hatten zunächst
wir mit uns so dass eine impfpflicht
nicht geben da gab es dann ärger dass
sie sagen warum sie diese umgekippt aber
also eine rationale erklärung
konnte ich nicht finden angst angst muss
ja auch nicht immer rational seien das
muss man ja auch ernst nehmen aber wie
gesagt am ende kippt ist meistens ab in
verschwörungs mythen ich würde doch
gerne ergänzen also eine ähnliche
erfahrung habe ich nämlich auch gemacht
weshalb die leute sich jetzt nicht
impfen lassen wollten da haben wir
eigentlich selten eine begründung für
bekommen aber die probleme die ängste
die die menschen haben die sind schon
real also eine frage zum beispiel
erzählt ich kann aktuell nicht in einem
geschäft gehen ich kann keine
weihnachtsgeschenke für meine kinder
kaufen weil ich bin nicht geimpft oder
ein mann sagt ich gehe eigentlich gerne
schwimmen ich darf im moment nicht ich
darf nicht an meiner sportgruppe
teilnehmen weil ich mir nicht geimpft
ich habe mit einer frau aus stuttgart
gesprochen und victoria 52 die gesagt
hat ich bin ich möchte mich einfach
nicht impfen lassen sie hat vorher als
pflegerin gearbeitet hat krebskranke
frauen zu hause gepflegt musste dann den
job aufgeben weil sie sich nicht impfen
lassen wollte bekommt hartz 4 und sagt
ich werde oder sie als wir uns getroffen
haben in stuttgart hat sie erzählt dass
sie eine woche vorher in der u-bahn
bespuckt und bepöbelt wurde und aus der
u-bahn geschmissen wurde weil sie eine
maske befreiung hat und keine maske
getragen hat also diese probleme die die
menschen haben sind schon real aber die
begründungen dafür weshalb sie diese
situation nicht ändern möchten dafür
eigentlich keine keine eindeutige
antwort bekommen danke für die
erkenntnisse